to think about the example of first
contact with gravitational waves so a
lot of people are interested in first
contact with aliens what will they look
like will they be you know on a
different planet will be some
interdimensional thing if you're getting
a little bit more speculative but you
know like what will that first contact
be like and my argument for thinking
about making contact with other life
forms is we have to have an
understanding of what we are and what
we're looking for before we design the
technology capable of making contact um
and part of the argument actually comes
from just thinking about the structure
of the evolution of our understanding of
gravitational physics um in the sense
that
you know i gave the example of newton
you know unifying terrestrial and
celestial motion and then einstein
unified space and time right in his
conception of gravity um and what he was
able to predict from that was this thing
called gravitational waves right so
gravitational waves are ripples in the
fabric of space-time if you didn't
invent a concept of space-time you would
never fathom these things could exist
the ripples in the fabric space time but
gravity's very weak force so they're
very tiny ripples um and what happened
was einstein put that idea out there and
people thought it was plausible because
of all the other predictions relativity
made but we weren't able to detect that
particular feature and it took
a hundred years
for us to build an interferometer which
is a very sensitive instrument they're
four kilometers across um they can
detect vibrations of a proton on the
scale of you know like a fraction of a
proton i think it's like a ten 000 the
width of a proton they can detect
perturbations do the rippling of the
fabric of space time and um in
2015 i think it was or 17 i always get
it mixed up um
we actually detected a black hole merger
that happened in our universe now that
black hole merger was an event that
happened 1.4 billion years ago in the
history of our universe because it was
14.4 billion light years away
and those ripples have been propagating
across our universe for 1.4 billion
years and it is only because
we happen to be a planet that evolved
intelligence that intelligence
identified certain regularities in the
world and formalized them in laws of
physics and develop technology to
measure properties of those physics that
when that 1.4 billion year ago event
happened to intersect our timeline we
actually could measure that phenomena
happening but what was happening on
earth at that time was we weren't even
multicellular we were just you know
microbes on this planet when that event
happened in in the past of the universe
so that's an intersection of some really
interesting things that have happened in
our universe the evolution of
intelligence detecting this event um and
actually recording it right so um so i
think i think you know you can
extrapolate that as you will to what
kinds of things we might find in the
future but i think one thing that's very
clear is if you have physical systems
that are capable of generating knowledge
as humans are and our biosphere is
um it causes really interesting
intersections between
what happens in space and time and what
gets
picked up basically by sensory apparatus
or detectors or things
so you were talking about you know us
beginning as
biological
systems and producing us
um
my understanding is that life started
pretty quickly on earth
yes
that's what we think yes and so evidence
is in favor of an early start
how
is that possible
what
what are the ingredients to
make that make to make life
yeah so um a lot of people that work on
the origins of life which is the area of
research that i i spend most of my time
thinking about is actually like how does
life even come to be in the universe um
think about you know trying to generate
an individual cell
and making some of the molecules that
are involved in biology now
and i think
i think that's not really the right way
of framing the problem i like to think
about the original life much more as a
planetary phenomena that some planets
actually transition
into this cascade of open-ended
complexity and evolution that we call a
biosphere
and some planets don't they just get
stunted
early on um and then it has something to
do with the geochemical complexity of
that world like what were the chemical
ingredients on that planet how were they
being mixed what was the density i i
think of like a density in in this sort
of assembly space what was the causal
density of like an amount density of
information actually generate this kind
of very
um uh this very different kind of
process and this different kind of
physics that we see in life and well i
watched cosmos and neil degrasse tyson
showed just how fragile life is yes it
is um well actually i you know i i
it's interesting when you're working on
this problem so much i come to disagree
with a lot of the standard doctrine i
don't actually think that life is that
fragile i think life is one of the most
robust features of our universe uh when
it evolves because if you think about um
i mean it is we are fragile in the sense
like if a meteor hit the earth you know
actually right but we're not fragile in
the sense that um
we are capable of inventing technologies
that can get us onto other planets and
also allow us to live in air-conditioned
homes at a comfortable temperature that
we don't have to fend for food and
biology has been constantly innovating
to basically increase its staying power
over you know four billion years um so
uh so i think i think if you think about
the most kind of robust processes that
can exist in the universe i think
intelligence is probably it as far as we
know um whereas all other sort of events
in the universe that we understand from
standard physics require specially tuned
initial conditions and some kind of
random chance of events um
like
so but intelligence is very reliable if
i know how to do something i can do it
again and i can do it again and again
if you say intelligence are you
talking about
consciousness
or are you talking about biological
objects ability to
have a feedback loop that
perpetuates growth and evolution
to some extent i might be talking about
both um and again this goes to the fact
the feature i was talking about earlier
so i'm glad that you're asking about
word choices because i think that's very
perceptive of you
um
that um
because the words are always imperfect
they're not very best yeah they're not
the best i wish we could communicate a
different way than language but we're
not there yet consciousness like as i
understand it as a scientist like the
future of consciousness that's always
mysterious and the one that you really
want to understand is why we experience
the world right so so usually in the
scientific community we separate
intelligence or even thinking about
neuroscience from the problem of
consciousness because consciousness is
in the sort of special bin where we're
not sure that it actually can be
addressed scientifically because um you
know i i'm having a certain set of
experiences of this conversation right
now and you are too but there there
doesn't seem to be any direct way of
building a map between what my
experience is in your experience or even
directly testing you have experience
because you you can tell me you're
having experience but how do i validate
and how do i look at the inner structure
of your experience from the outside it's
it's not um
it's it's not um it's not that it's a
it's a well posed problem but it's not
necessarily well prose for science and
sometimes you know uh when i think about
the long term future
um you know pending we survive long
enough there there might be something
beyond science not like like science was
invented right and it's a really
rigorous way of thinking about reality
but there might be some ways of thinking
that are even better than sciences that
allow us to probe that question directly
sure i mean neil degrasse tyson said
that the his greatest fear was that
he didn't know the right question to ask
yes yeah no that's that's a
that's very
good i also agree but on the the nature
of consciousness i do think there are
ways of thinking about it from the
outside what might be happening on the
inside and the way i think about that is
to say like if you thought about
imagination as something that you want
to explain from physics um imagination's
kind of a weird thing right so um the
example i like to give is like rockets
the idea of rockets have existed on this
planet for hundreds of years but we only
were able to build them in the last
century so is that an example of
something that existed only within minds
and maybe minds writing on paper
but then was actually physically
generated in the universe because those
minds had access to that idea they
invented that idea before they generated
physical structure so i think when you
were was there two two options did you
just
the well i think no i think that's what
like i think that's a good probe into
what the nature of consciousness is and
i also like to think of consciousness uh
more in terms of sets of collective
interactions so i have a colleague in
japan takashi kagami who you know was
trying to play around with the idea of
whether consciousness was contagious
which i think is kind of an interesting
concept could you learn consciousness
from interacting with another physical
system so in the context of like could
we teach robots to be conscious by
interacting with us in a meaningful
interaction
um but
and that raised for me interesting
questions about are we only conscious
like even though consciousness is an
internal thing maybe we're only
experiencing consciousness because it's
actually a collective property it has it
requires groups of minds interacting
because it's actually about the
information we exchange with each other
that actually is our conscious awareness
so um
so i think those are all sort of
plausible ways of maybe formalizing
theories of consciousness that could be
tested
um
particularly the imagination when like
if you imagine that counterfactuals
things i could imagine could exist but
don't exist now could be caused to exist
by an entity that could you know a
physical thing like me that can invent
them i mean the reason i think about it
this way is exactly what you do when
you're trying to make a theory of
reality right so
when you're trying to sit down and
you're trying to say i'm looking at all
of the patterns that i see across all
life all the ways that we talk about it
and i'm trying to make an abstraction a
set of ideas that allows us to now
control that phenomena not control it
but like actually understand it in a way
that we can now use it for different
things and
and gravity again is the example like
why can we watch that satellite launch
satellites into space right now we can
do it because we looked at a certain set
of patterns in the world and we were
able to come up with this abstraction
that explains a large class of them all
the things that are gravitationally
interacting and then we use that to
develop technology to be able to do
things we were never able to do in our
history uh same thing with time i mean
like the invention of clocks and the
progression of our ability to use clocks
and keep track of time i mean seconds we
take for granted now it's like you know
seconds are passing when we're doing
things but for most of human history the
idea of a second was
impossible because they had no no id no
capacity to keep a record of a second